[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mirror economist susie boniface and the
deputy editor of conservative home henry
hill so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now well the
eye takes a two-pronged approach
reporting on the pressure being exerted
on boris johnson by conservative mps
after the local elections results it
also mentions the police investigation
into whether sakirshama and his labour
colleagues broke the law by eating and
drinking together during lockdown
the financial times describes the prime
minister as being under renewed threat
the guardian is unsurprisingly blunt pm
blamed for tory election disasters
the times their headline tories punished
in south
but the express focuses on the other end
of england and offers a strikingly
different take declaring bullish boris
back on track as red wall keeps faith
the telegraph hears there are concerns
for the likelihood of a united island in
the event of a shin fan victory that's
despite their leader michelle o'neill
insisting that's her goal
back to so-called beergate and the male
dubs the labour leader slippery stammer
on that same story the sun goes for a
pun also are you going to calmer quietly
sir
the mirror proclaims snubbed reacting to
the news that prince andrew and the duke
and duchess of sussex won't be invited
onto buckingham palace's balcony during
the queen's platinum jubilee
celebrations next month
and the star has heard that the cost of
living crisis has led to a massive surge
in australian visa applications from
people in the uk
strut the headline there and a reminder
that by scanning the qr code you'll see
on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us
and uh we are joined tonight by suzy
boniface and henry hill welcome to you
both um let's start uh with the ft
weekend and uh tory mp's are applying
more pressure on boris johnson's
leadership we're told henry
well it's difficult to see
what this pressure is because tory mps
clearly for one reason or another do not
want to
they haven't moved against him at the
height of partygate and at every
subsequent opportunity they've drawn
back now it's important to say that
compared to where we thought we'd be 24
hours ago when projections were saying
that a a good a bad night but not too
bad a night boris johnson was 250 losses
we're now i think of more than 450
losses this is a really really bad set
of election results so yes fine clearly
something needs to change but what we
really need is some detail about what
these mps want him to do differently
yes that that is the question isn't it
susie uh what would they like him to do
aside from from leave
well exactly and i don't think they
really want to do that because as him he
says if they really wanted him to leave
they would have done something um by now
i think i've just seen that we're
heading up to 486 yeah tory lopsis at
the moment um which obviously could
could go even higher before the end of
the night um but i think probably the
prime minister is is thinking he can
just roll with this and it isn't too bad
the principal reason being that he
doesn't have a challenger vishu sunak
has been
neutralized because of his wife's
non-dom status which is very
inconvenient and the only real
challenger who's been on maneuvers is
jeremy hunt and if anybody thinks that a
man who's capable of getting half the
nhs out on strike is the answer to their
political problems then they're living
in cloud cuckoo land so we're getting to
the point where we're two years out from
the next general election
and
they need to get someone in now if
they're going to be able to fight that
on on a fresh footing um and it doesn't
look like they're going to be able to
move quick enough which means then
they'll just sort of end up in a
situation where they go into the next
general election with a massive cost of
living crisis
inflation that probably won't have come
down
um and whatever will have fallen out
from partygate by that point
uh because they simply weren't able to
move fast enough and so i think i think
they've got boris for the long term and
i think boris thinks that as well i
think he's probably right
but yet uh he was the reason that many
people said they simply couldn't vote
for the conservative party in the local
elections so he's being blamed for for
the
problems they're experiencing at the
moment though isn't he henry
he is i mean if you you just need to
look at the way that local conservatives
have been campaigning around the country
in in worth they literally called
themselves the local conservatives to
try to put a bit of distance between
them and the national brand all over the
country council leaders kentucky
councillors were urging voters to vote
on their records which are often to be
honest pretty good rather than the
national picture this isn't just an
english problem i was speaking to some
of the welsh conservatives today they've
had an absolutely miserable night uh
they had an absolutely miserable day
sorry after after yesterday and they
were saying that actually time and again
their message was cut across by the
stories coming out of westminster the
scottish conservatives uh lots of them
are probably rightly blaming the fact
that douglas ross didn't put enough
distance between himself and boris
johnson the fact that they lost 60 plus
councillors so yes absolutely whatever
else has happened and there are some
long-term trends at work here there's no
doubt that the prime minister is a
significant contributing factor to this
drugging that the party has had and they
do need to face up to that and if they
if they are going to hold on to boris
johnson as leader we need not just hope
but a clear plan for how he's going to
turn that around uh the express a
slightly more positive tone um saints
actually went uh well
especially in the red wall for the the
prime minister are they clutching at
straws
susie do you think
there are a little bit but it's true to
say that labour certainly hasn't done as
well as it would have hoped everywhere
hasn't hasn't really rebuilt the red
wall significantly and that those
long-term trends that henry was talking
about the fact that labour vote seems to
have moved to more affluent more urban
areas and the tory vote has moved to the
poorer perhaps more working class areas
that seems to still be the case that
hasn't really overturned the other way
and so both parties have got a
disconnect between their traditional
heartlands and where they're actually
picking up votes now and how do they
actually manage to make that work the
one positive thing for labour probably
is it's done very well in scotland and
scotland of course would be
very necessary if it was going to win a
general election but we don't know quite
happiness anyway yet i don't know if
either of you have what the turnout is
yesterday general elect local elections
are generally much lower than generals
so it's entirely possible that people
just stayed away out of boredom or
disgust or whatever it might be and just
didn't take part and therefore the
actual picture when you get to a
national vote we could be very different
in a couple of years time i think
probably moving from what harry was
saying about what boris is going to do
next and what he can do what the
government is going to do to overcome
this if you had a government right which
was listening to the people that heard
what just happened here and thought
right we need to change what we do and
how can we fix this for next time then
that i'd have some optimism that there
would be some kind of meaningful change
i think what we've got
it's it's feels to me like the same as
we saw at the end of the
brown and blair years and the end of the
major and thatchy years which is a party
that's just been in government for too
long
you know after after the third
administration they've lost it they're
out of touch with people and they tend
to get to the point where they think
they're owed the votes and they they
take their finger off the pulse and
that's when they when they lose big and
i i just get this sense of sort of end
of regime
sense about things that are going on
hopefully
um you know there are people in there
who are going to be trying to convince
them otherwise but i think we can expect
perhaps a light reshuffle moving pretty
patel slightly further away from rwanda
maybe uh and a bit of what you they'll
call a government reset which is you
know exactly what we've seen every time
boris has been in trouble before and
helps me change my mind henry do you
agree that with susie there that they've
simply just been uh in power for too
long or do you lean towards the the
expresses headline which says that
actually boss johnson back on track now
because the red wall have have kept the
faith
back on track to do what i think is the
question because the other thing about
this government is it's got an overall
it's got no majority of 80 which is all
very historic and it did get blown off
course by the pandemic as any government
would have but the question is what is
boris johnson's government trying to do
it's backed off planning reform it's not
doing any of that we read today that
it's much touted digital safety bill is
in trouble this isn't a government with
an exciting domestic agenda it's not
doing anything much about the cost of
living crisis there's just no sense
there's this urgency this sense of
urgency from boris johnson's allies you
know we've got to keep boris we've got
to keep going but there's no sense of
where the tory party is supposed to be
gritting its teeth and wading through
all this blood to get to and i think
that's the problem now this isn't
inevitable after being in power this
long the party has changed leaders
several times it would be perfectly
possible i think to have a a new vision
there's definitely lots of problems that
need fixing i just think that boris
johnson likes being popular he doesn't
like facing down his critics he doesn't
like spending political capital or
making tough decisions and if you have a
man like that in charge of a time like
this what you get is drift and delay and
eventually disaster
let's move to the telegraph and northern
ireland and the vote there they're
speculating that uh fears about a um uh
united island are coming to the fall now
susie
yeah so shin fein have actually seemed
to be looking like that they're going to
be the most popular party which would
mean that for the first time the first
minister would be the you know the
nationalist party that seeks a united
island and uh they've said that that's
one of the things they're going to push
for but then it throws open this the
whole situation of how the northern
ireland assembly works so it's set up so
that the first and second ministers are
you know from the main two parties
unionist and nationalist and they must
share that power and it looks like the
dep is probably going to refuse to share
power with shin fame just on principle
which means the assembly collapses it
just doesn't doesn't operate
well they're saying they're not going to
share power unless the northern ireland
protocol is is sorted out exactly well
but the dep's got all these problems
because they they wanted brexit they
campaigned for brexit when they got
breaks if they complained about how
brexit actually turned out to be uh it's
lost a lot of support in northern
ireland plus there's a huge number of
people
which are voting for more centrist
parties in ireland now than northern
ireland that they've just moved away
from these sort of two tribal opposites
that they've had for so long and trying
to move towards the center ground so
shin fame although you know many people
associate it with the ira it it looks
more modern and it's it's talking about
some slightly different things the dup
seems very rooted in its original
fundamentalism and you've got this new
centrist party coming through it
probably means that we're going to have
to think again about actually how that
northern assembly is the constitution of
it is set up because if it just keeps
collapsing because
one bunch of wing nuts refuse to talk to
the other wing nuts then i mean that's
the whole point of the northern assembly
was you get all the wing nuts together
and they actually make friends and if
they're not going to do that then you
have to think again about how it works
henry we've just got less than a minute
to um get an update on beergate day 10
in the daily mail
well i mean the police have announced
that they're going to investigate secure
statement they apparently um held that
decision back for several days so it
didn't affect the vote which has
irritated some tories but yeah i think
it's reasonable enough in the
circumstances um
if he's found
to have broken the rules then he will be
hoist by his own petard and based on
what he said about boris johnson i think
he will almost certainly have to resign
but i don't think we've got any grounds
for pre-judging the investigation the
police will do what they're doing i
think again this highlights what this
whole saga highlights really is one of
the most just unjust things about the
covid restrictions was just the fact
that the police had so much discretion
with how they went about enforcing the
rules despite the fact that the
consequences for individuals could not
for politicians but for ordinary people
often be so severe
susie very quickly if there is found to
be a case for secure to answer should he
resign
he's going to have to as henry said
because that's what he's demanded of
boris johnson but i think before we get
to that point uh now that the local
elections are out of the way the
metropolitan police are going to be
moving their own investigations further
forward and remember the prime minister
is accused uh of being present at six
parties and he's not just holding beer
indeed but ended up with some people
being faced down at the flat
we are out of time thank you both good
to see you thank you see you next hour